For years, Marvel fans have asked for a solo
movie centered on Black Widow.
She's appeared as a supporting character or
popped up in a cameo in "Iron Man 2," "The
Avengers," "Captain America: The Winter Soldier,"
"Avengers: Age of Ultron," "Captain Marvel,"
"Captain America: Civil War," "Avengers: Infinity
War," and "Avengers: Endgame."
Up until this point, she's been the superhero
equivalent of a bridesmaid without ever being
a bride.
That all changed on July 9th, when Black Widow
finally got the solo adventure she so richly
deserves.
The movie accomplishes a great deal within
its 134-minute runtime.
It proves Natasha can save the day even without
super-human powers.
It gives her death in "Avengers: Endgame"
more meaning by showing how much her found
family within the Avengers meant to her.
And it introduces a ton of fun, new characters
that have the potential to pop up in other
Marvel projects.
If the "Black Widow" post-credits scene is
any indication, Natasha's sister figure Yelena
Belova will be seen again, but we also hope
this film isn't the last time we see Alexei
Shostakov, aka the Red Guardian.
He's effectively the Russian version of Captain
America, who believes he's on equal footing
with Steve Rogers, and is essentially the
walking embodiment of the Cold War.
Plus, he has more than a few tattoos to show
off his heritage.
When Natasha and Yelena break Alexei out of
prison, we get a good look at the various
tattoos he's acquired over the years.
One of these will only make sense if you can
read Russian.
On Alexei's bicep, you might notice two roses.
Inked underneath the flowers are a couple
of Russian words.
Translated into English, these words are actually
the names: "Natasha" and "Yelena," respectively.
This shows that all of these years later,
Alexei always remembered the two girls who
pretended to be his daughters while they lived
in the United States.
It's a vital Easter egg because Alexei, Natasha,
Yelena, and Melina Vostokoff weren't a biological
family.
They were put together by villainous forces
to spy on Americans, and after they escaped
from Ohio, they didn't see each other again
until the events of "Black Widow."
It would be easy to assume Alexei didn't form
an emotional attachment to his faux daughters,
but as his tattoo attests, he always carried
a part of them with him.
If you look carefully, you may notice that
in addition to the rose tattoo for his "daughters,"
he also has one of his "wife" — Melina.
You have to look on his left-hand side next
to his neck.
There's an image of a woman sporting a bob
haircut, and there's no doubt about it that
he's memorialized Melina on his skin.
Out of all the tattoos featured on Alexei's
body, actor David Harbour has said that Melina's
portrait holds a special place in his heart.
As he told Variety,
"That was probably my favorite one because
I love Rachel Weisz."
That's likely a big reason why when they finally
reunite, they flirt with each other like old
high school sweethearts.
Hopefully, the two rekindled their relationship
when they went off together at the end of
the movie.
It would be awfully awkward if Alexei dated
other women on the outside and had to explain
why he has Rachel Weisz's face on his shoulder.
You might've also noticed Red Guardian has
writing on his knuckles.
No, he's not a Hells Angels member with "love"
and "hate" on his hands.
If you pay attention, you may realize what
he actually has written across his fingers
is "Karl Marx."
Marx was a philosopher best known for writing
"The Communist Manifesto," and his ideas played
a significant role in the formation of the
20th century Russian Revolution.
It appears Marx's ideology is alive and well
in whatever prison Alexei was locked up in
for so many years.
As a symbol of the Soviet Union, it makes
sense for Alexei to have tattoos celebrating
Russia's history — and that's not even the
only one he has on his body.
In an interview with Inverse, actor David
Harbour mentioned,
"There's other stuff that's personal, stuff
that's communist.
He has a tattoo of Lenin on his belly, I don't
know if you see it."
The Red Guardian getting Vladimir Lenin tattooed
on his body and having Karl Marx's name on
his hands is basically the equivalent of Captain
America getting a giant tattoo of a bald eagle
on his chest and having his knuckles read,
"John Jay."
We suppose that option's still available for
John Walker to do.
"Black Widow" is now available to watch in
theaters and on Disney+ with Premier Access.
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about your favorite
TV shows and movies are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit the
bell so you don’t miss a single one.